so another question what is good for
respiratory mucus whether it's in the
lung whether it's a chronic bronchitis
or chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
lung conditions asthma sinus infections
sleep apnea mucus deep into the sinus
cavities it's right here
using salt not necessarily taking salt
but breathing in salt there's a machine
called a hallo generator which basically
gives you something called hallo therapy
which is breathing in salt air
so this machines basically take the salt
and ionized it and put into the air so
you would have it running when you're
sleeping at night it can actually loosen
up the mucus in your lungs and your
sinuses and your throat salt has the
capacity to make mucus thinner its
antifungal its antibacterial its anti
mold so it's really good so I'm gonna
put a link down below of a couple
different options I'm not affiliated
with any of these companies but I saw
some really good ones that you can
either do a neti pot or you can get a
device that generates salt air right in
your room while you're sleeping oh one
more thing you really want to check for
any mold in the house because if there
is mold or mildew that could be enough
to keep your lungs constantly filled up
with mucus and you'd be surprised you
change your environment and go into a
different location also in this the
sinus mucus completely goes away so it
could be a source of the actual cause of
your mucus from a nutritional standpoint
the regular oil is really good for mucus
and garlic and fasting but if you can
actually do a longer fast let's say
every month for a 48 or 72 hours you can
put your body in some serious it's
called a tapa G which will help clean up
the deep old damaged proteins and
improve your immune system and also
deactivate viruses in the body clean up
microbes it's a really good thing for
your immune system but oregano oil is
also good for that as well if you have a
virus and sometimes it's a combination
of fungal back
and even viral then olive leaf extract
is what you need to try alright so those
are my recommendations for getting rid
of this thing right here thanks for
watching if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos